hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our match
between paul charles murphy and johanna
yacob
from the 1858 uh and uh
well uh currently the score is eight to
three in morphy's favor eleven games
have been played and if you're only
joining in now
do check out some of the links in the
description below you can either
watch the entire paul morphy saga from
the beginning so you know everything
that's happened so far
or at least if you don't have the time
check out the previous video in the saga
which is
uh well the previous game game 11 of the
match which we called
uh levanthal's immortal as it is quite
uh quite the game and
a very significant game in the match so
that being said uh let's
check out what happens here and how
morphy deals with
uh well just losing a game and not just
any game as
as we said it was logan tells immortal
uh
so morphy with the white pieces opens
with e4
with e6 we have the french defense by
levanthal
d4 and d5 and morphe does something you
should never do
uh he plays the exchange french e
captures on the e5 we have captures and
bishop to d3 not right away of course
but first knight to f3 we have knight to
f6
and only then bishop to d3 and now
bishop to d6 nowadays is an automatic
you want to castle as soon as possible
uh but here uh we have the older
continuation bishop to e6
kind of saying i'm not i'm not going to
allow you to play c4 because then i'm
just going to capture it
here we have castles by morphe and
bishop to d6 only now we have knight to
c3
morphy continues development and the c6
now strengthening the center
and that d5 pawn uh with knight to e5
immediately grabbing more space in the
center and now
queen to b6 and uh it is as of move
eight that this position has never been
reached again so
uh the d4 pawn is under attack and the
morphe defends it with
bishop to e3 uh and while doing so
invites
black to capture on b2 is it possible to
capture on b2
uh well it is are there better moves of
course there are
uh your king is still in the center of
the board you might want to castle first
so here first
knight b to d7 uh continuing development
and uh
saying to morphy i might castle kingside
but i might also castle queenside
depends on well depends on what you do
so here morphy just uh strengthens his
grip in the center he plays f4
and now bishop captures an e5 with f
captures and the knight
to g4 puts pressure on morphy's bishop
on e3 and the queen to d2 just
continuing development
uh while defending the bishop here and
here we have uh
knight captures on e3 bilomental queen
captures
and now he feels very comfortable about
grabbing this pawn so queen captures on
b2 now putting pressure on the knight
here and
knight to e2 so it seems that uh luintel
grabbed the pawn successfully
and will not be paying any sort of a
price for it
uh so queen to a3 you of course are
expecting a rook on b1 so queen to a3
you want to be able to uh to bring your
queen back
and knight to f for now so maybe
this little pawn grab is just enough
maybe this is just what morphe needs
uh to start some sort of an attack here
and here uh indeed if you go for
something like
castles uh you run into some very nasty
stuff like bishop captures an h7 check
picking up the queen
so you can't really just uh just castle
okay
it's not that simple so first queen back
to e7
now uh you are ready to castle and now
rocate to b1
saying okay you're free to castle but
you have to give back the pawn
so indeed if a castle you can just give
back the pawn and it's uh well it's
questionable how
how good this will be for you because
you still have a backward spawn here
your knight is now pinned you have a
well a problem with the rook on b7 the
other rook can come to b1
could be could be problematic uh another
thing you could do is you could try to
play b6
uh defend the pawn and say okay i'm just
gonna castle on the next move but it's
also not that simple because of knight
captures and now if f captures you will
not be castling kingside so queen
captures and now bishop to f5
again poses some problems for black for
example queen e7 and now queen to c3
again goes after the pawn
and it's uh incredibly easy for black to
make a mistake here
would black find a move like knights to
b8 here which really hinders development
or would he go for something like rook
to c8 which is completely losing
uh it's hard to say for example rook
beat the e1
and now you say okay what do you do now
black castles and now queen to h3
with a double attack threatening to pick
up the knight while also delivering
checkmate
so it's uh it's a very difficult
position to play
so after this rook a to b1 uh lointel
says okay i grabbed the pawn i'm just
gonna castle queen side and everything
is perfectly fine
uh but morphy says uh nope uh not not so
easy and he starts uh
re-maneuvering bishop to e2 so uh
what's happening here well knight to b6
uh the knight can now come to c4 which
is a very important uh
square and now the bishop moved so the
queen can come into the game
queen to b3 now for example if the
knight moves you can just deliver
checkmate it's uh it's a very nice setup
here queen uh on b3 and the rook on b1
so rook to d7 black says okay i'm not
having that the knight will be able to
move and
the rook and queen will be guarding the
b7 square
so knight back to d3 uh morphy says all
right i'm going to claim the c5 square
for my not for my knight and
knight to c4 and this is where the fun
really happens
uh because now morphy does go knight to
c5 and now there's a question
is knight to d2 any good i mean there's
a beautiful fork here to rooks and the
queen
uh in fact it is it is the best black
has for example knight to d2
but it's not that simple queen to g3 now
offering uh one of the rooks
for example knight captures on f1 bishop
captures and now
black has a problem because this is
hanging and this is hanging
and you really have to figure out how to
go about this now would
would would black be able to find b6
here
uh allow the capture of this rook it's
hard to say or rather would he try and
save the rook
and then you just run into well knight
captures on b7 is
just a very ugly move to face because
after rook captures bishop a6
black just completely falls apart so it
is a very
interesting position uh however after
this knight the c5 move element i'll
play rook to c7 first
he said okay i'm just going to move the
rook and the knight to b2 is my next
move
i mean it's definitely happening however
morphy plays queen to a4
now knight to d2 does not come with an
attack on the queen and you will just
have to face queen captures on a7
followed by queen to a8
so here uh king the b8 not really the
greatest because of this
check uh the king and rook are in uh you
know
uh being for fork here you cannot
capture and after the king moves you
will first capture on c4 to prevent any
future
forks then you might capture on c7 or
depending on
what white plays it's just going to be a
very messy position uh much favorable
for white
so instead of moving the king we have b6
now
attacking the knight and here well here
morphy goes for bishop captures on c4
and recapturing the bishop doesn't
really work because here you have rook
captures on b6
and black completely falls apart you
have
queen a6 check followed by rook to b8 or
if you capture the rook it's not much
better
queen to a8 is checkmate because the
knight covers the b7 and the d7 squares
so after this bishop captures on c4 we
have uh
well this doesn't work so we might as
well capture the knight we have b
captures on c5
and now bishop the a6 with check with
king to d7
and now we reach a beautiful position a
true morpheus position
uh because you know everyone can attack
where it's easy to attack where there
are some attacking moves but how do you
attack
uh where it doesn't seem all that clear
that you
should be attacking or if there are any
attacking moves
uh well this is where morphy really
thrived and where where he found the
beautiful attacking move so feel free to
pause the video here
and try to find the only move that wins
here for white uh
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it uh congratulations
as it's really not an easy move to find
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's
uh bishop to b7 and now it seems like uh
well yes okay it's a fine move but what
does it do
really uh well it does a lot actually
for one it prevents the rook from
entering the game for example any rook
to b8
action can just be met with bishop
captures check you pick up the rook
it's uh that that part simple and
well the only problem in the
continuation of the game is that uh made
it too easy for morphe he played rook to
d8
but let's just check what happens uh if
you play with the
most proper defense uh which is queen to
h4
you have to give to give the king one
extra square uh
to you know be able to move and also you
don't allow any captures here because
the queen would hang on a4 so it's a
it's a very good square for the queen
you're also threatening to pick up this
d4
pawn with check and trade queens however
uh c3 defends the pawn for example
rook to d8 now you bring the rook into
the game and now queen to a5
uh threatening queen to c5 while also uh
going for that
d6 square and now after black plays c
characters on d4 doesn't really matter
queen c5 and queen back to e7 uh trying
to trade queens as you've just
grabbed more material now comes the uh
the intended move
which comes from the bishop to b7 idea
bishop captures on c6 and here black
just falls apart
uh the king has nowhere to go if you
move the king you lose the queen and of
course if you capture the bishop then
just rook b7 check
and that's it rook has to block uh rook
captures on c7 check doesn't really
matter king g8 and
queen captures on e7 so this is what
happens
with best possible defense after bishop
to b7
that's why bishop to b7 is the only
winning move here
however longtail made it a bit too easy
for morphe he played rook 28 right away
uh depriving his king of one very
important
uh square and here morphe just played
bishop captures on c6 and it was in this
position that yohanyako blumenthal
uh resigned the game and uh it's on move
25 so quite quite a miniature for
for uh for paul morphy and it's a shame
for
logan tell he just played his immortal
game on the previous game now
after game 12 has been played uh
it's uh well it's gonna be it's gonna be
incredibly difficult for him to
to come back in the match but we'll see
what happens the match is still young
so here you resign because after
captures the rook is pinned and then
rook to b7
is deadly there's nothing for you to do
you cannot block you cannot move the
king because you lose the queen
so you might as well defend with this
king to e8 move
but it's still with check captures and
out the rook uh falls as well
uh it's not really something you want to
you know uh
even try playing and another thing after
bishop captures is
you can go king to c8 that's true but
now comes
queen to a6 check and the king has
nowhere to go you have to start blocking
rogue b7
but then just rook captures on b7
attacks the queen threatens a lot of
nasty discoveries and there's
there's nothing for you to do here like
you could block you could move the queen
it's
it's silly to even suggest the move here
because whatever you do it's made into
let's say rook d7 you're gonna get rook
captures on d7
check uh the king has nowhere to go only
only move king to b8 and now of course
rook to b1
uh or queen to b7 everything is
checkmate doesn't really matter
uh so yeah uh wonderful game by by paul
morphy wonderful attacking game
uh there were some chances for lumental
if he played that knight to d2 move
right away instead of waiting for uh for
morphy to really
uh get his attack going but after that
after he morphed found bishop to b7 it
was just all over
uh and uh what uh what a nice bounce
back in the match
not not not really a bounce back score
wise but as low intel really played a
spectacular game
uh in the previous game it was it's
definitely a nice uh
game for morphe to bounce back with and
like i said if you haven't seen it do
check it out
it will be the first link you see in the
description below
uh so yeah uh that's uh the game another
game in the paul morphy saga i do hope
you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank paula [ __ ]
juan vincent alvarez
uh eddie latzell uh mr mr space bar
there
uh pablo mohan and rampaging corporate
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the paul
morphy saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day